-Now welcome back to the show.
We are hanging out with Josh Gad
and Andrew Rannells.
They star...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-...in Gutenberg! the Musical!"
Right now on Broadway.
Get your tickets.
And in this show,
you play a ton of characters.
And you change
a lot of --
You change roles
by putting on hats.
So I thought it'd be fun
to play a brand new game
called "Celebrity Hats."
Here we go.
-Brand new.
-Okay.
-♪ Celebrity Hats ♪
-Now here's how it works.
It's just like
the game Celebrity.
But instead of cards,
we're going to use hats.
Each of us will be wearing --
We can put them on now --
a stack of hats with celebrities
names written on them.
The object of the game
is to guess the name
on your hat,
while also giving clues
to the other players.
-Okay.
The only rule is you can't say
the name of a project
that the person has been in.
-Yes.
-All right.
Your person is named Cher.
[ Laughter ]
-I don't think --
-That is -- He is correct.
You're allowed to do that
if that's the rules.
Is this Cher?
-Yeah.
-Damn, I think I missed --
-Thank you.
I think
I misunderstood the game.
-I think you did.
-All right, give me --
Give me one.
-Well, I will tell you,
I think you're a big fan of me.
I'm a big.
-Have I slept with me?
[ Laughter ]
-No.
This person is doing
a residency in Vegas
And she's, I think...
-No, you can't talk about
any of the projects.
-This person is Adele.
[ Laughter ]
-What is going --
No, stop saying that.
You're playing it wrong.
-All right.
-You're playing it wrong.
You're playing it wrong.
Wait.
-Do you want one?
-Who am I?
-Okay, yours --
Yours would be like,
Hey, are you coming soon?
Are you --
Are you on your way?
Andrew Rannells?
No, it's a -- it's a line
you might say like, are you...
-That is your
impression of him?
-Do you want me to do
an impression?
[ As Arnold Schwarzenegger]
"You'll be back."
-Oh, Arnold Schwarzenegger.
-[ Normal voice ] There you go.
Now we're playing the game.
-All right.
-All right. Ready?
Here we go.
Okay, Take it off.
-Oh, uh, she loves Kelce.
She loves --
She loves...
-Taylor Swift.
-Yes.
-Yes! That's you.
Okay.
-Yes.
-Do me.
-All right.
-Um, this --
-Strong.
-This guy's really big.
He's so muscular.
The Rock.
-Yes.
Okay.
She's going
to let it go.
Idina Menzel.
All right.
That's correct.
-Switch.
Take your hat off.
-[ As Nicolas Cage ]
"Oh, I can't believe you."
-Oh, Keanu Reeves.
-No.
-Uh, uh...
[ Laughter ]
-"It's not your face.
It's Travolta's."
-Oh, Nick --
It's Nick Cage.
-[ Normal voice ] Yes correct.
-Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Take your hat off.
You're still
on Taylor Swift.
-Oh, I am?
-Oh, yeah. Take one off.
Um.
-Oh. Oh.
-"I'll never let you go, Rose."
-Yeah. And also...
-Leo DiCaprio.
-Both: Yes.
-Yeah.
You -- You remind me of
Leo DiCaprio a little bit.
-Josh Gad.
[ Laughter ]
-Yes.
No, no, but...
Yes, yes, but also,
I think in more like
a more playfully way, maybe.
-Let me see.
Let me see.
-Oh, he's mentioned
in our show.
He's a little tiny
little slip of a thing.
-Josh Gad.
-No, uh.
"Dune,"
"Call Me by Your Name."
Oh, "Call Me by Your Name"
-Oh, Timothée Chalamet.
-Yes.
There you go.
All right, here we go.
-All right. Take mine.
-Oh, oh, oh.
-She's mentioned in our show.
She's in concert right now.
She's not Taylor Swift.
She's beautiful.
-Beyoncé.
-Yes.
-Yes, that's right.
-[ As Robert De Niro ]
"Hey, I don't know."
-Oh, De Niro.
-Yes, that's correct.
-All right.
Take your hat off.
Take your top hat off.
Oh, this guy.
-"Point Blank."
-"Point Blank,"
"Speed."
-Keanu Reeves.
-Both: Yes.
-Oh, oh.
He's an "Avenger."
-He's a name.
Long name.
-Very long name.
And he loves Shakespeare.
He loves playing
Hamlet and "Avengers."
-Oh, God.
-He either plays
an Avenger or Hamlet.
[ Laughter ]
-Uh --
Stop yelling --
Stop yelling at him.
-Oh, my God, you're the biggest
movie star in the world.
-No, you wouldn't yell!
You wouldn't yell!
-No, you're the biggest...
-You wouldn't yell like that.
You wouldn't yell like this.
You wouldn't yell.
-No, he would jump on the couch.
-You wouldn't yell like this.
-He would jump on the couch.
-You would jump on the couch.
-Oh!
-He would jump on the couch.
-Your guy would jump
on the couch.
-My chair.
My guy would jump?
-Yes.
-Your guy jumps on couches.
-Tom Cruise.
-Both: Yes.
-Oh, you -- you -- you --
You are --
You are the Grinch.
The voice.
-You're the voice
of the Grinch.
But you're also
a damn Avenger!
-There are so many Avengers.
-You're the one who can fly.
-You have red hair.
You have red hair.
-Benedict Cumberbatch.
-Yes.
-I won.
-Wait.
-You are the voice of God.
-You're the voice of God.
Josh Gad.
[ Laughter ]
-No.
-Oh, Morgan Freeman.
-All: Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
My guests,
Josh Gad
and Andrew Rannells.
Their show
"Gutenberg! The Musical!"
is now on Broadway
at the James Earl Jones Theater
through January 28th.
Stick around, we've got more
"Tonight Show" after this.
Come on back.